good afternoon everyone
dear Ursula
honorable president
of the European commission it is as
always an absolute pleasure to meet you
not
simply because
this is what politeness dictates and
diplomacy that I should say this but
because realistically speaking
we have really felt
the European Commission
under
your leadership
closer than ever before
and the sensitiveness
the sensitivity which was recognized
even when you served as minister of
defense
towards this part of Europe the Western
Balkans
has been emphasized I would say even
more
and it has become more tangible
with you at the Helm of the commission
we are absolutely aware of the fact
that thanks to you personally
we have had
even stronger and larger support than we
would have normally had after the
catastrophic earthquake
off a few years ago
just as we are fully aware of the fact
that even now in this situation which is
so difficult for everyone not just us
yet again
thanks to the approach of the commission
vis-a-vis the Western Balkans
and of course thanks to your personal
approach
yet again
we
Are Not Alone
therefore
I wish to thank the president
wholeheartedly for the Stop in Tirana
we have been together
just now to see the works of the new
Railway
and at last
in this case
not because of bureaucracy or red tape
in the commission but another type of
bureaucracy of the ebrd instead
the project
has commands much much later than we had
envisaged however we find ourselves in
the situation in which we can say that
in the spring of 2024 we will have the
railway access Tirana to Doris and
Tirana to do the serenas and rinas
durasteran
on the other hand
it goes without saying that today's
meeting was of Special Value and
significance because the president
informed us about the whole situation
financial situation
in the conditions or for war in which
bombs and wounds
have been felt across the Ukraine
however the repercussions of these bombs
and wounds are also felt across Europe
including us here in Albania via the
stratospheric prices of the energy
Market
and also by way of inflation which has
touched us all without excluding anyone
unfortunately I informed the president
of our approach
of our resoluteness that we will
continue to support in all ways shape
and form
families households the small businesses
so as not to touch the price of
electricity and what this means is this
a considerable weight in the state
budget
but we believe that this is a reasonable
way to carry nonetheless and on the
other hand we have also spoken a little
but we will meet again later on an
extraordinary
um event for Albania the first of its
kind in
the history of
and that in history and that is on the
6th of December in Tirana we shall have
the EU Western Balkan Summit
with the Western Balkans
and of course that means that all of the
EU leaders and leaders of the western
Balkans shall come to Tirana for this
Summit so in other words Tirana
in the most impressive way if truth will
be told
the stage of a European uh Final in
football
for actually not the final but there's
still it was at the first half of the
year and now it becomes the stage of a
huge European political event
of the highest level in the second half
of this year so therefore I would say
that in this aspect we're talking about
two events with just a few years ago
nobody could have possibly conceived
let alone for us to live through all
this so I thanked the president
also in relation to this matter because
I am absolutely convinced that in the
possible
elections even though she won't accept
this and she she won't probably accept
this to me you have been tirana's
Advocate thank you
thank you so much
already
visited image is
time
addresses
foreign
there is
foreign
foreign
Monday
foreign
modernism
um Hydro centrality of years
then in fact
energies electric and events practice
series
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so the first question to the president
of the European commission Madam
president the European Union is engaged
by a way of this fund of 80 million
euros in terms of energy
and other than financial support to the
energy sector the crisis is not really
just about that but it's about fuel as
well increase of prices therefore
inflation has gone up when wages have
been devalued so we also have data that
when we're going to a reduction of
economic growth annually is there a
commitment on the part of the EU that
other than to the energy sector there's
perhaps a fund for all of the matters
that I just mentioned and the same
question to you prime minister do you
expect now that Albania has officially
opened accession negotiations with the
EU further support other than just the
energy sector and secondly 80 million
euros how much to what extent does it
meet the needs of Albania's energy and
these 80 million Euros are the sort of
help so that the government can push or
withdraw entirely from the increase of
42 lakh over 800 watts
so
um
the response per jija decreases
energetic
inflation and foreign
foreign
foreign
attack Energy Arena of wash my data
infrastructural energy
structures
but indeed
thank you
thank you so 80 million euros
I'm not so little by far
there are considerable amount of money
and in order to answer the question as
to
what part or what percentage of the
whole need this would meet for us to
continue to maintain the same price for
households or families and consumers
it's one-sixth
so if we were to refer to this year for
instance
we have had to in total up to the end of
the year that is according to the
provisions bearing in mind what has been
done so far 460 million euros this is
the figure combined between the state
budget on the one hand and the operator
for the production of energy
it is of course uh gobsmacking figure
when it comes to the entirety of our own
budget however it is the sort of figure
which has helped also in terms of
inflation
despite the fact that in your screens on
your screens and in the various
information
portals or Pages this thing perhaps is
not seen or talked about or written
anywhere EX in fact the contrary takes
place and the lack of Truth to Albania
today has the lowest inflation in the
region
and the main reason not one of the
reasons but the main reason for this low
inflation or lower inflation is so it's
the lowest in the region by the way
again despite the fact that inflation is
never low or in times of War because
this inflation has been brought about by
the war not our government or the
European Union
so it is the fact that we have a shield
a financial Seal Shield for Energy
prices so if we
would have
um made the shield relative
even if we had touched upon Energy
prices ever so little by approximating
it to the market when it comes to small
businesses Enterprises this would have
been reflected in all prices for
families and households but fortunately
no points of sale in Albania
God
have
a price of electricity which has been
changed on the contrary
the same price electricity price is pay
is being paid now as was the case prior
to the uh energy crisis this is a fact
secondly
I hear this repeatedly this question
will you withdraw give up from the
increase in electricity prices we will
not increase electricity prices we have
never said that this will be at the 800
kilowatt uh stage that is not actually
increasing the price it is placing a
ceiling under which every single
household family
can meet all of its basic needs and when
I say basic needs I mean everything
without the need of any more this has
been already calculated
and over 1 million consumers
or
1.2 million consumers that is who have a
contract with the electricity operator
it's basically
the
there's very few families that will need
to go above the ceiling at the height of
the need for either heating or cooling
purposes
so this is an entirely different thing
all together to
the vocab you're using which is the
wording of increasing energy electricity
prices nonetheless even with regard to
this and in particular when it comes to
psychological effects
and of course in terms of
creating a filter
vis-a-vis all of the lies and all of the
Fabrications and the poisoning daily
poisoning of public opinion with
untruths
which have terrorized the whole country
about energy prices going up which is
the hugest lie possible
we on the other hand
have pushed the application of this fog
for October not because that is what we
wanted because if it was just about what
we want or wanted there wouldn't be a
capital or wages would be doubled
pensions would be doubled but these are
related to what we can actually do are
what we can do but there were two
preconditions first of all we did have
um rain not as much as we would have
liked but sufficiently
to consider this as an opportunity and
secondly we saw that there is a
reduction in consumption so this means a
positive behavior in terms of saving at
this present moment we can see on a
daily basis when it comes to
precipitation rain there's not much to
see because everybody can tell that our
sky is absolutely blue
every day it shines the sun shines
through so that's bad news in a way but
our days are beautiful but when it comes
to saving yet again we see positiveness
so there's a reduction a lowering of
consumption and if people were to save
reasonably then
the possibility for us to act
differently with this cap then we can do
so and because we did so for saving
purposes and this absent alarm ringing
of bells
it does it does away with the fact that
800 kilowatts was placed as a cup to in
Kosovo ages ago ages ago it's still
there unconditionally just so that we're
clear
and I just do not find that it has
touched the people of Kosovo it has
affected them because it doesn't affect
everyone
whereas in relation to the question that
was asked to the president of the
commission we need to be fully aware of
the fact that the European Union is not
in the con in conditions when there is a
huge cave with gold and now is the day
to open sesame the cave and all of a
sudden all of the gold will flow upon
all of the people because this is
happening no this is times of War this
is the a time of War we did not pick
this war we perhaps alone cannot stop it
this war is a fact and it is not the
sort of war that has no bearing on us
not simply because it's it's because of
inflation as well but there is a bearing
on us because of the contents of this
war
contents
I understand
that the cons economic related concerns
might make somebody think and what do we
care about the war no we do care about
the war we do care about the war because
we need to continue to have what we have
today Freedom democracy and
the fact that we belong to this large
family which is threatened now the
European family which is under threat
because Vladimir Putin did not go to the
Ukraine simply for Ukraine's sake he
went there because he wants to bring
Europe and the West to its knees the
whole of the western democracies on this
side of the globe
and this is a bet
and kneeling the Western democracy
bringing them to their knees is
precisely
that which he cut off the gas
two-thirds of the supply which have been
cut it increased prices and of course
um he wants people to go out there in
the streets and to refuse what had to
reject what we have already achieved and
change our mindset about our way of life
and therefore in this context we of
course
the 80 million will not be it it's not
like we don't need any more but still
they will help and we're very grateful I
am very grateful president of the
commission and the commission we would
like you to know that we are grateful
just as we will Levy attacks the
extraordinary tax
by following the European directive by
seeing what some countries have done
that is the tax of three energy large
energy producers and yet again here can
you please be very accurate and precise
with the public so don't just talk about
the tax for all hydropower plants but
this is for the three three largest
operators in the country
um who haven't done anything to sell
energy in multi-fold so there's nothing
we don't have anything against them
but they can't just have uh gobsmacking
profits just because these times as such
now and for us not to be able to support
those who are most in need no so we will
have this extraordinary tax and by the
by collecting that tax we will directly
support those who are most in need
of course
what the president mentioned are very
important Investments That is and
one thing which was not mentioned is
what we discussed
on the joint investment
for azer al-fazerbaijan
EU Azerbaijan and our countries
for the pipeline
for the uh Adriatic Union or Union
pipeline
which will connect
the trans-atriatic pipeline to
Montenegro and Croatia and this will be
an added value of course for our country
Albania will have a trend a difficult
transitionary period
to come out to another level altogether
because by way of the Investments that
we are doing in terms of solar energy as
well as the other Investments
for
liquid gas
in 2025 by 2025 we will have 100 percent
of our capacities and needs
when we have sufficient precipitation
whereas when there is no precipitation
whatsoever we will need
to continue to invest for 2029
Irvine coach
a2cnn a question to both of you the
president and the Prime Minister you
both mentioned the summit of the 6th of
December what are the expectations of
this Summit thank you
my expectation is for them all to come
to Albania to land in Tirana all of the
leaders of Europe
add the the bulk the Western bulk and
leaders have come here frequently so of
course by it being a summit that focuses
on the western Balkans for us to discuss
these very topics
to see what has been done to take stock
of what has been done and what can be
done jointly
for the following year up until the next
Summit because
there's Synergy now very positive
Synergy between the European Union on
the one hand and the Western Balkans on
the other and despite the fact that we
are not EU
that
um he has been understood completely and
equally their European we're your
opinion they have the union the youth
for the union but we're still European
and fate
when it comes to Faith and Destiny it is
a joy in Destiny therefore I believe
that we have made historic advances
when it comes to the relationship
between the EU and Albania as well as
the relationship between our region in
which Albania plays a first-hand role
and the European Union a historic one
thank you
foreign
foreign
and given the fact that there are no
other questions according to the
agreement that has been decided with the
other delegation I wish to add one more
fact that along with all of the other
delegations that will come to Tirana on
the 6th of December there will be a lot
of journalists
who belong to the journalism who deal
with politics and the majority of whom
regularly have thought and still think
that Albania is a is a dangerous country
they will come here
but they will live exactly the same way
which is there is only one danger in
Albania that it makes you fall in love
with the country and of course you have
gone through this love but that's why
you have lost this love for this country
thank you
[Music]